we wash so I wanted to talk to people
about the different states of matter
solid liquid and gas using water as an
example but about first I better be sure
that we're all on the same page about
what water is made of what's water made
of hold on yeah what makes water water
okay what elements does it take to make
water h2o so what does that mean it is
water
what elements water and cold water plus
cold but what is the H in the omen
uh um some linked in oxygen something in
oxygen hydrogen hey go Jin hydrogen and
oxygen what's the to mean hydrogen
oxygen and the to h2o why don't we say -
ah I don't know
it's - Park was a hydrogen and one of
oxygen there you go so that that makes
what we call our water come to two atoms
of hydrogen and one atom of oxygen makes
uh water
hi molecule thank you
I know the word was like on the tippy a
time I guess we got there in the end
so what's the difference between solid
and liquid water uh so that obviously
the temperature of it it's LA colder um
ice is frozen what does it mean to be
frozen that carl's Li food waters no
good for skating on ice is great yeah
nothing of the temperature so everyone
recognizes that temperature is important
in determining whether the water is ice
or liquid well what's actually happening
between the water molecules towards the
difference between water and ice that's
frozen
what does it mean for something to be
frozen solid
or what does it mean for something to be
solid that it's like a brick okay it's
like a brick and what makes it like a
brick what's happening in there but what
makes it a solid versus liquid well on
in this case lots of pipes going
underneath but that's a very cold makes
it very very cold yeah but what's
actually happening to the little bits of
water they're attaching to each other
it's actually their attention this is
this is all do we guess work here I
imagine they're attaching to each other
they're forming a more solid enter piece
you cool liquid water down and then at
some point what happens to it it slows
down freezes and stops moving the
molecules become frozen how do they
become frozen they joined together they
uh accumulate they coagulate coagulate
is not the technical term for it but
everyone was on the right track in ice
the water molecules are basically fixed
in place they form a crystal lattice
where their only motion is vibrating so
what happens if we heat up the ice like
how what happens when like a solid melts
they all bounced out and what are we
talking about what it what is they what
are they doing Oh like in science you
draw little circles what are those
little circles oxygen are they just
oxygen hydrogen oxygen in the two and
the two the temperature is higher so the
particles they're less stable yeah less
stable stable miss more free to move
around fans right they become separate
and they are allowed to move around and
in gas maybe they're further apart is
that it is that we're okay astok sighs
now they're all right that makes sense
that's all right
so in liquid water the water molecule is
not only vibrate they can also rotate
and slide past each other and this is
what allows the substance to flow at
even higher temperatures the water
molecules become free of that liquid and
turn into water vapor in that state they
are very very far apart and moving very
quickly so the major differences between
solid liquid and gas are the motion of
the particles and the distance between
them of course you may want to meditate
on these
references some more what about the
difference between a solid a liquid and
a gas
oh that's easy I teach meditation and
it's all about the as UD excite
something so UD excite the mind you get
more orderliness as you do excite water
vapor you get water as you D excite
water you get ice more orderly so in
fact the molecular structure becomes
more orderly that's the difference that
sounds very reasonable how do you do you
excite something well in this case you
actually remove energy from it in human
beings you calm their minds down with
meditation and that works because yeah
does that mean if I meditate too much I
might turn into ice stuff maybe you'll
generally become cool good answers there
thank you so much